i mean for me i feel like i haven't
changed much
like my look apart from the only thing
that's changed is the spikiness of my
hair
over the years you can calm down you can
tell the gigguk years by the younger i
am
like the more spikes in the hair yeah
like there are you look at some of my
first videos and i look like [ __ ]
sasuke man
i'm wondering right like how did you
decide on that hairstyle because that's
like
that's a look is that is that is that
like hair you've had since we were young
or no i think i can't remember i just
remember
because i have like hair that's really
easy to be spiked up right
so i think everything constitutes hair
that's easy to spike up
like light and uh oh okay i mean like
could you spike up your hair yeah easily
if i had
no no because my hair like if i cut it
short i put a bit of water in it and it
just
like immediately like naturally it's
just like the the [ __ ] anime
character spike a lot of like asian hair
has that too because like my hair is
also like quite strawy
so like if i put gel in it it's just
[ __ ] up forever i don't know
like yeah no i get that but like but
then again it's like
just because your hair can do that it
doesn't mean you have to like
it was that okay was it inspired by
anime no no it wasn't
like what was the inspire it was
inspired by there's only a
there's only so many hairstyles i could
pull off and i had no idea what the [ __ ]
i was doing with my hair
therefore look it it was the hairstyle
that took the least amount of effort to
do
because all of you no no no no it was
not okay it wasn't
because like like i said my hairstyle is
just naturally spiky so all i would need
to do
just put a bit of water put a bit of gel
and just go
no because it was it was done it was
done yeah
it naturally like it naturally went to
that shape
naturally yeah naturally sonic the head
i just woke up and i was sonic you know
like what can i say no because like i
remember in some older videos
your hair is like so it looked like a
wig that's
like that's how that's how perfect the
spike was i was like this man could pass
off as like a side character
it was like you'd been watching too many
like david bowie concerts
all right i like that i'm gonna i'm
gonna mimic that
basically that's what it looks like yeah
i i wasn't trying to mimic anything i
had no i just had like no idea what the
[ __ ]
it was like some guy who was like trying
to bring back like the 80s glam rock
scene because
it's like when whatever the mr anime you
talking about that video
it's so funny watching that and seeing
god just like with like this teenage hat
yeah just being really sad i feel
bad but like because obviously you're my
mate i'm like oh it's funny
like if you didn't know the context and
you just saw the thumbnail it looks like
the most like angsty [ __ ] video
it it is it totally [ __ ] is it's just
i i can't focus because your [ __ ]
hair is like sonic the hedgehog what
you're talking about like 60
of the frame you're talking about like
argue like the most serious thing ever
and you've got like this [ __ ] sonic
hair
i can't focus on it yeah because i'm
just talking about
yeah this guy just like killed him but
bro that [ __ ] hair though that
[ __ ]
wow this man's hair has its own orbit
oh my god yes welcome to trash chase
where we are on each other
now now we're trashing on each other's
hair cards as as good mates do what what
that's what we do that's what
constitutes a mirror like can you really
call your maiden mate if they don't make
fun of you after a haircut
okay like did okay like did you re did
you what age did you reach where you
actually like
paid attention and gave a [ __ ] about
what you looked like because i was like
really [ __ ] late yeah because
literally the reason i looked like that
was because
i didn't really give give a [ __ ] about
what i looked like right until i
got to like my first second year of uni
yeah i was probably about the same did
you ever have any interest in dating
when you were
you know you didn't never want to like
date a girl in school
are you interested i was on all boys i
mean of course
i love my boys
[Applause]
i don't care what you look like it's all
right yeah no like yeah i i guess maybe
it's because i went to a boys school
that
not to say that i didn't hang out i
[ __ ] would love to have gone to boys
school yeah even got the pressure of
having a [ __ ]
trying to get a chris yeah yeah yeah
i've got a girlfriend because everyone
else is getting one yeah yeah i mean you
know not to say that i didn't have any
interest in dating but it's just like it
wasn't a priority for me but i was speed
running them in school man
i never had one that lasted more than
like two weeks oh yeah i mean that was
school relationships yeah
i had one that lasted like three months
and the boys were like damn you lost
three months if you lost more than
that's a long time
high school it's a long time that's a
that's a dedicated relationship anything
beyond a month
is like okay i am dedicated to this
they're probably getting married you
know
exactly it's like one step away from
marriage right three months like damn
my life's set already after this i think
i must have started paying attention to
like how i looked at maybe
well okay i see how i looked the hair
basically like everything else was like
what am i gonna wear a [ __ ] school
outfit you know
oh yeah my mom still bought all my
clothes so like yeah
i'm not gonna lie i didn't start buying
my own clothes until i moved out no same
thing no same
same right yeah my mom was just like
yeah i got this nice t-shirt it was like
some shitty
five dollar t-shirt from target i was
like yeah [ __ ] i'll wear that my mom
still buys me clothes and sends them
really it sucks that she's [ __ ]
better taste than me you know what's
weird aki's mom buys me
but my own mother doesn't anymore i
remember us
we did a shoot like uh like a week ago i
remember joey had to borrow one of your
one of your t-shirts and just seeing
joey in one of your like t-shirts i'm
just like
this is such a connoisseur because it
was just like it was just like
a plain t-shirt it's literally that but
a different color it's a plain t-shirt
in a drab
color and i'm just like man this this
just screams corner right now
it's a color that i would never buy and
it's a color that
connor would definitely it's taken okay
this could be another one of those weird
conor things right
only like last year have i been open to
the idea with owning
shirts that have nothing but plain color
right
for some reason in my head is it because
you don't like logos or i hated logos
and prints they drove me insane
why i don't know for some reason it just
looked cheap to me and always
and that's i mean it's kind of you know
i guess
because normally they're cheaper these
these yeah
it depends because some some some of
them
can look very tacky and i feel like
there's a fine line between having a
cool print
and having like a cool piece of artwork
that just looks tacky on a t-shirt
yeah yeah like you know it's the whole
concept of like simple as best
yeah sometimes you know that's like the
whole reason why like all those like
high brand shirts and [ __ ] like that are
so [ __ ] simple i mean i think i think
that's what's
changed my opinion of like fashion in
general is like i have started to be
more open to spending a bit more money
on clothes
because at the end of the day it's like
all right i'm wearing this [ __ ] for like
how many months
yeah i'm gonna be on camera as well
especially so like i want to wear shirts
i mean
you know today i'll see i'm still i've
still got a little bit of the old me
like yeah
yeah obviously recently i've been like
okay i'm willing to spend like
all right might spend 80 bucks on
t-shirt which is unthinkable to me three
years
oh yeah absolutely because bear in mind
in university i used to get a primark
which if you don't know what primark is
in the uk i've done i've been a prime
minister yeah sure but primark's amazing
by the way
it's basically about [ __ ] on prime mark
i'm gonna fight you on that well i mean
it's you know i i don't want to question
how they make the shirt so damn cheap
yeah i'm sure there's some ethical
questions
i remember i specifically bought eight
t-shirts for 10 pounds
which is like 15. it's amazing and i
[ __ ] loved these shirts because they
were all plain yeah yeah yeah
nothing on them and i wore them for like
two years straight these shirts oh yeah
they were [ __ ] [ __ ] by the end of it
right for real though primark is like
one of the best
low-budget kind of clothing brands i've
ever seen
globally yeah honestly like like the the
[ __ ] you can get for the price at
primark
which i don't know where primark's
available internationally because
i think is it in europe yeah it's it's
like if you want a budget place where
you can just buy cheap clothes that
don't really
don't look cheap you know what i mean
because people said uniqlo here is cheap
and we have unicorn in the uk it's it's
not cheap
you know clothes compared to primer
primark is like yeah very
uniqlo is cheap for the quality that you
get yeah like you'll pay a little bit
extra for like a t-shirt at uniqlo but
that shit's gonna last you like 10 plus
years
i i bought a whole suit from primark for
like
forty dollars 30 pounds the 30 pound set
yeah
yeah i did exactly the same for my
prominence my graduation i
and actually i hate to say it but it's
like it doesn't look that bad right
it's not bad it's not that that's the
thing i mean primark
basically carried my universe the years
you know what i mean
but there's a big but and a lot of
people in the uk tend to also have the
same mindset i think where
a t-shirt should never cost more than 20
30 pounds yeah yeah yeah which i can
understand because if you know you've
got a lot of money spending that much on
one t-shirt it's really
quite a lot it's quite a lot yeah but
you know as i started to
uh i think that's where my my hatred of
prince started i thought a lot of these
primark ones are pretty [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah and they often you look super
tacky
and i don't i don't really like the
collaborations they have like spongebob
and [ __ ] and then all that yeah they oh
yeah
we suck at playstation logo i think
they're just starting to do anime as
well
yeah which is where they i feel like was
it last year where they did like a
dbz or one piece collaboration as well
yeah there's been a lot of stores like
that like forever 21 as well before they
went under like they did this like
huge [ __ ] thing with anime so like
every time i went to forever 21 there
was always like this
entire section of anime but when you
look at it when you actually go over to
it it's just like all right let's see
what they have it's all like
sailor moon dragon ball z yeah
me that [ __ ] and it's not even done in
like a creative way either it's just
like let's just slap the logo and the
main character yeah
like doing anime clothes is really hard
and we're i'm probably going about to
like call out like a bunch of our
viewers by saying this but like
the ones i hate the most are the ones
where it's just like it's just a t-shirt
with a wifey on it
an anime logo like those kinds of
clothes i call like anime convention
clothes
because it's it's it's a t-shirt or
clothes that i would only wear at an
anime convention
but there's no way i would wear it you
know what i call clothes like that
pajamas this is the only time i'm
[ __ ] wearing it
is when they need to wear something in
bed but there's someone probably someone
watching this right now and like a
[ __ ] arsenal t-shirt to be like
oh but i like this yeah i mean i and
then like i think as well going back to
the whole cheap versus expensive stuff
yeah for clothes like it's only because
i think as i moved to japan and actually
started seeing like some of the clothes
that i like
really like and it's like kind of
expensive but you're like okay i'm gonna
wear this a lot
like when i paid like 350 bucks [ __ ] for
that that
diavolo uh sorry king crinsom jacket
yeah yeah yeah like when i bought that
that was the most expensive thing i'd
ever bought like clothes wise and i
think oh my god this is this is insane
but this is this peak
this is insane 350 dollars on a [ __ ]
jacket okay it's sexy look on screen
it's sexy
but now that i've been wearing it i wear
like pretty much every day
yeah like i'm like okay if i'm wearing
it every day you know and i get like
maybe
four or five years out of that that's
like 20. you're getting a bank right
yeah exactly
like i understand that because i i
always thought that way with tech right
like to me it's like don't buy a 20
headset buy a hundred dollar at least
yeah because yeah you're gonna get your
money's worth yeah
and i don't know why for some reason
took me so long to have that with
fashion and i think going back to the
whole topic
which is school and why i didn't give a
[ __ ] is because i didn't i just didn't
care for clothes i didn't really
understand fashion at all i mean i i
there was always that one kid in your
school who somehow always [ __ ]
dressed amazing to [ __ ] you don't have
that kid i didn't have that kid
i did not have that kid i i always i
don't know i i had kind of like a
similar view of fashion which is
just i didn't get it i don't know i
didn't understand anyone who would
spend above like yes 20 to 20 or like 30
on the t-shirt i think my mum would like
scoff if my if an outfit was over
total 50 dollars she'd be like look at
the get a lot of this guy
i think that's the thing though it was
that at least with me there was this
like because it was a boys school but
there was this whole i guess like stigma
of people
if you dress well then you're you're gay
like that whole [ __ ] all right so i
think people just
i'm sure there were boys who actually
did give a [ __ ] about fashion
but they didn't want to with the because
they're probably worried about getting
beaten up and like
i get that you know like it's it's like
yes a fedora might seem quite
fashionable you know in the common eye
but why would you wear that if you don't
want to get bullied you know like that's
true
like i like wearing fedoras i i think
they look [ __ ] cool with the right
outfit
but but the problem is i love i'm i'ma
agree with joey
yeah i feel like i feel like the prob
the big problem with fedoras
is that the like the [ __ ] neckbeard
community
completely ruined that hitler mustache
you can't wear it because hitler's
ruined it well
it's the same thing with the fedora you
can't do it because you're gonna
everyone's like in the salad that's the
thing
that's the thing but it's like but
that's the problem i feel is that a lot
of the reasons why fedora is just
commonly seen as that type of you know
negative thing is because
the the hat itself is fine it's what you
pair it with
yeah it just makes it look like absolute
dog [ __ ] well you thought you're either
gonna look like a neck beard are you
gonna look like a rip off michael
jackson
right now in between i mean i'd rather
look like a rip off michael jackson than
a [ __ ] neckbeard right
but like but like i've seen other then
you can truly enjoy your lolly wife
like i've seen i've seen like fashion
magazines of like dudes who like
you know wear a fedora or like a hat of
some kind that's similar to a fedora
in like a really nice suit yeah and they
can match that [ __ ] but those are like
the most [ __ ] attractive men on the
planet well that's what i'm saying yeah
right and that's that's the other
problem is that there are no attractive
men who wear fedoras
i'm just saying i'm just i'm just
preaching to the choir right now but
you know that's true i mean i'm not
going to lie and pretend i know how
fashion works you know i know
i'm
i feel like having that one kid in
school who elevated the game really
[ __ ] elevated the
elevated the game in school he was the
benchmark he was he was the trendsetter
really making me look [ __ ] bad you
know when he turns up with his jeans
with holes in them i'm like how can we
compete i don't have holes in my jeep oh
wait
what am i supposed to do